so
i just did what i consider to be one of
the most difficult things to do
in my profession of acting which is
to walk as yourself
this is the first time in my life i have
ever actually talked about my work
in this way i didn't go to drama school
the first time in fact i remember seeing
drama at all
was when my mother took me to an amateur
production of
ham it was a cataclysmic experience a
darkened space
with a group of people watching
something and they're
transformed by it
i would like to share some of the ways i
work
never act in front of a mirror you are
doing the exact opposite
of what acting is about acting is all
about what's happening within you
it doesn't matter what's happening on
your face
it's a collaboration between us all your
costume designer is incredibly important
in building your character a russian
with a bad wig
and these glasses nomination likewise
the environment is going to tell the
story of the character
as much as the costume is
i knew nothing at all about working in
front of a camera
now this is what happens just before you
do a take
at this point you have to cut all this
stuff out
and when the director calls action you
don't have to start acting straight away
of course the beautiful moment is
between you
and that little spot next to the lens
i remember this feeling so well and many
of you will feel it
when suddenly you're in control of it
i felt i was on this incredibly powerful
horse
but i had the vocal ability i had the
intellectual ability
for that all to settle and now i could
play with it
the moment where your technique is so
deep within you
that gives you the freedom then to
invent to improvise
to act i'm helen mirren
and this is my master class
you